[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Well, thank you so much for
the generous introduction--
generous and pretty
comprehensive.
And thank you all
for coming out.
Thank you for showing up
if you already know me,
and I hoped you would show
up for validating my hope.
And thank you for
showing up, especially
if I didn't know you'd be here
because that's an extra treat.
So the presentation I'm
giving has three parts.
The first part is
called departures.
It deals with how I get started.
The second part is
about itineraries--
what I am touching on, where
I'm landing in this research
project.
And the third part I'm
calling intersections,
because it's where the
subjects of my research
converge with other
disciplines and diverged
from disciplinary currents
to meet up with others.
This presentation is dedicated
to the memory of my late friend
André Lancaster,
who was a black,
gay playwright who wrote plays
and musical works and helped
produce and workshop dramatic
works by black playwrights
on fantastic and science fiction
and Afro-futurist themes.
André Lancaster is really an
influence without whom I would
not do the kind of work I do.
I was not about to
be the only black,
gay André who did work
on speculative fiction.
And I think he would be
really excited to talk
about dramatic performance with
me as this project proceeds.
I'm glad that he will be
able to see it somewhere.
In 2016, I published
my first book,
Speculative Blackness--
the Future of Race
in Science Fiction.
This book is the culmination
of about a decade of research
starting in graduate school
into phenomena that demonstrate
the workings of two
categories that I
think are really central to
literature in popular culture--
race and genre.
Like most academics,
my research is in part
the process of self-discovery.
The texts that are
integral to this project
are among those that define
me as a black professor,
a scholar, and a fan of science
fiction and fantasy narratives.
The archive of
Speculative Blackness
reveals a lot about me
insofar as it shows you
what I paid attention to
in the course of setting
my agenda as a
researcher, and what's
left out of it is as telling
as how it's put together.
This is the table of contents.
And if you recognize some
of the titles on this list,
one thing you might notice
is that there is not too much
direct engagement
in the analysis
of conventional literary texts.
But there is a
fairly broad range
of media in the
scope of what I call
and what lots of other scholars
call speculative fiction.
To be succinct about
it, speculative fiction
is a $10 word for a $5 concept.
It's an umbrella term for
science fiction, fantasy,
and horror, sometimes
mystery, sometimes things
called cyberpunk and slipstream
and the grim and the weird--
all of those things.
It includes time travel, space
flight, robots, vampires,
aliens, and ghosts, as well as
the other worlds and utopias
envisioned in the distant
past, alternative histories,
and possible futures.
I analyze these
narratives in some
of their most well-known
and influential iterations
and some that are just my
favorites-- the various TV
series and the Star
Trek franchise,
the X-Men comic books
and independently
published comics
from Milestone Media,
and fan cultures, including
fanzines distributed
on the amateur
publishing circuit
and the informal
networks that gave rise
to today's world science fiction
conventions and Comic Cons.
Some of the fiction writers
that you might recognize
who are involved in this
study include AE van Vogt,
Paul Anderson, Harlan Ellison,
Robert Silverberg, Suzy McKee
Charnas, Jewelle Gomez, Wilmar
Shiras, Charles Saunders,
Steven Barnes, and JK Rowling.
But there are two conspicuous
absences from this catalog,
and they're really
the most prominent--
for a while, the
only prominent--
African-American
writers to contribute
to the science fiction
and fantasy traditions
and make their
livelihood doing so.
Many have tried, not all succeed
in commercial or in prestige
terms--
Samuel R. Delany
and Octavia Butler.
My reasons for omitting
these authors from the book
are pretty straightforward.
Other critics have
written enough about them
to bring their work to
the attention of scholars
and casual readers.
Delany, the first
African-American author
to win the Hugo award for
outstanding achievement
in the fantastic genres,
is among the living authors
recognized by the Science
Fiction Writers Association
as a grandmaster for his
contributions to the field.
He's written dozens of
novels and short stories,
autobiographical
works, including
a memoir in graphic novel
form, literary essays
and social criticism,
pornography, published diaries,
letters, interviews, a few
issues of Wonder Woman,
and reflections on writing.
A radio play based on
his work is the subject
of this presentation.
The late Octavia Butler was the
first science fiction author
to win the MacArthur
Foundation Fellowship--
the "genius grant."
And her writings are
especially instructive today
as we live through the
political, environmental,
and economic
developments foretold
in her novels Parable
of the Sower and Parable
of the Talents.
Her works appear in
numerous anthologies,
and they continue to provide
inspiration to readers,
artists, and activists,
especially black women,
as demonstrated by the artistic
collaborative Black Quantum
Futurism and Adrienne Maree
Brown's Emergent Strategy.
While I might have discussed
these two luminaries and any
of a number of other
authors to supplement
the material in
Speculative Blackness,
I'm turning to them now as
part of a book-length study
with a really different scope.
As you can see from
the divergent objects
in my research so far, I
don't conceive of genre
as a medium specific category.
So accordingly, I
consider what happens
at the intersection of race and
genre meaningful across a range
of popular media in literature,
as well as in popular culture,
in written forms as well as
orally, in forms that we hear.
Examining popular culture
through the lens of genre
entails making connections
between disparate narratives.
It means finding patterns
in different materials
and identifying the problems and
tropes that link them together.
The organization of my
first book, for example,
reflects a concern with
the movement from margins
to mainstream, the interplay
between consumer practices
and professional
creativity, and the tension
between ideological capture
and utopian possibility.
In my current
project, I'm trying
to maintain one more
or less coherent object
within the focus of my
analysis and exploded
into several dimensions.
The object in question is the
science fiction radio play,
an art form I've never
studied until now.
In addition to
the curiosity that
draws my attention to
works in this tradition,
I'm interested in
texts that allow
me to return to the familiar
ground of blackness and science
fiction while learning
new lessons to share.
And appropriately,
this investigation
starts where I left off
with Delany and Butler.
The works by these authors
that I've tasked myself
with studying this year have
some significant qualities
in common.
They both originated
as print fiction texts
before they were
adapted for listening
audiences in radio formats
unique to their respective
historical moments.
This pattern doesn't hold
true for every radio play that
would be subject to my analysis
in the book project I foresee,
but it's instructive as a
demonstration of the role
that literary adaptation
brings in to drawing together
different segments of the public
to interpret, to learn from,
and to apply the knowledge
explored in different stories.
Before delving into detail
about one of the examples
that I've mentioned
today, let me
offer an overview of some of
the contents of this new project
that I've named audiofuturism.
The Star Pit by Samuel
Delany is a novella
that first appeared
in the February 1967
issue of the science fiction
magazine Worlds of Tomorrow.
Delany would include the story
in the first collection of his
fiction Drift Glass in 1971,
but first he adapted it
for a performance that
was recorded and broadcast
on 99.5FM in New York City.
The Star Pit is a slice of
life reflecting the experiences
of an Earth-born,
heavy drinking,
African-American spaceship
mechanic named Vyme
as he moves through radically
different but intersecting
social circles on the
space colonies that
have become the home of the
human race in the future.
The Star Pit is a place.
The other exemplary
topic for this study
is Kindred, a 1979 novel by
Octavia Butler with a truly
terrifying premise.
The protagonist, an
African-American woman
named Dana, who
lives in California,
is pulled back in time to
19th century Maryland, where
she must bring about the
circumstances leading
to the birth of one of
her enslaved ancestors.
Kindred was produced
as a radio play in 2002
for a web-based
internet radio program
launched by cable's
science-fiction channel, Sci
Fi.
These works by
African-American authors
represent touchstones
for the relationship
between racial discourse,
speculative fiction,
and popular media.
Either of them might
have been the basis
for a chapter of Speculative
Blackness, but neither of them
was.
In this new phase
of my research,
they're equally important
alongside other works that
demonstrate different facets
of what makes radio drama
such an enduring tradition.
Even as the way we
read and the way we
listen changes, as science
fiction becomes science fact
or more often as we ignore
the warnings of the Cassandras
and Jeremiahs among
us, a combination
of nostalgia and
innovation keeps
radio drama alive as a venue for
imagining unseen possibilities.
If we look further
afield, we encounter
the prototypical science fiction
narrative as a radio play--
the 1938 broadcast of an
interpretation of HG Wells' War
of the Worlds.
This story of an invasion
from Mars originally published
in 1898 is one of the
most adapted and widely
translated texts in the history
of modern science fiction.
But its movement
across the Atlantic
and across media in the early
decades of the 20th century
are what make it
truly evocative.
As always, I'm most
interested in this narrative
and in the renditions it's
gone through because it takes
on questions with world
historical significance,
questions like, are we
alone in the universe?
Why do we want to explore space?
And this question, which I think
is not posed nearly enough, how
have the colonial legacies of
the modern world, especially
the captivity and
enslavement of my ancestors,
set the stage for the way
we comprehend what it means
to live on the same planet?
The War of the Worlds
situates these questions
within the plot of a
thrilling adventure.
It propels them forward,
but its frequent revisions
and translations also
preserve previous generations'
encounters with the problems
of life on Earth and Mars.
The novel by Wells
models speculation
by bringing recent telescope
observations of the red planet
to life.
It also stokes the fears
of an empire in decline
by twinning the constant
threat of rival colonial powers
with newly articulated
racial anxieties that assume
the shape of yellow peril.
The alien sounds of
The War of the Worlds
are engrossing in and of
themselves, but to me--
and therefore for
our purposes today--
there are no stories with
global significance, especially
this one, that we can
separate from the genealogy
of modern white supremacy
and its consequences.
With that in mind, I'll
bookmark the other chapters
of audiofuturism before moving
on to the preliminary treatment
of Delany that I have
devised to share.
One chapter will regard
a science fiction
farce, The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy.
In March 1978, BBC Radio
aired the first installment
of an ambitious radio drama that
would become a cult classic.
The novel first appeared
in print in September 1979
after the radio play.
In 2005, African-American
rapper and actor Yasiin Bey,
then known as Mos Def, costarred
in a US-based film adaptation
of the saga as the
protagonist alien confidant,
the man who was supposed to
be an alien assuming the form
of an everyman, a best
friend to any earthling--
Ford Prefect.
A new sixth
installment in the saga
is being broadcast this year.
The most unwieldy chapter
I'm likely to write centers
on a performance
first staged in 2014.
Jace Clayton, a
black American sound
artist who employs the
persona DJ Rupture,
created The Julius Eastman
Memorial Dinner preserved
in recording as The Julius
Eastman Memory Depot,
an interpretation
of provocative works
by the black, gay experimental
composer Julius Eastman,
who died in 1990.
The performance is strung
together by a speculative radio
drama set in the near future,
in which Clayton plays
a character auditioning for
the role of a Julius Eastman
impersonator.
I intend to return
to subject matter
close to home with the last
chapter of the project.
It will focus on black
British playwright
Patricia Cumper's adaptation
for BBC Radio of Toni Morrison's
haunting novel Beloved.
This program was
first aired in 2016.
At each site on the
itinerary of audiofuturism,
I hypothesize that
something weird
happens when speculative fiction
gets translated into sound
or gets translated from
sound back into print.
Sometimes I'm concerned
with the reproducibility
of textually prescribed
sounds in a script,
like the infantile
stream of consciousness
in which the title
character of Beloved
voices anguish from
beyond the grave or--
[BUZZ] a Martian heat ray.
In addition to these
genre-specific sounds that
rehearse tropes of fantasy
and science fiction,
I'm also concerned with
verbal and nonverbal sonic
elements that stage real
and imagined interventions
in racial discourse.
These strange
sounds are my point
of entry into discussing Star
Pit now and Kindred later.
The most valuable resource
for the radio play
based on The Star
Pit that I've found
is an essay written
by Samuel Delany.
I came across the
essay online while I
was revising the manuscript
for Speculative Blackness,
and I didn't know what to do
with it until years later.
In "Notes on The Star
Pit," the essay, Delany
recounts his
novella's publication
in Worlds of Tomorrow magazine
and the subsequent casting,
recording, editing, and
broadcast of the radio play.
I followed the
leads in his writing
to the Pacifica
Radio Archives online
where the radio
institution disseminates
the product of a
Grammy Foundation grant
to preserve recordings they
produced from 1966 to 1969
through the 99.5 Radio
Theater in New York.
The Internet Archive
at archive.org now
hosts digitized versions
of the recordings
from WBAI's archives,
including The Star Pit,
along with other
programs in the series.
The recordings
include original works
on contemporary and
historical themes,
both fact and fiction, poetry
and experimental wordplay,
dramatized readings of
historical documents
like the letters of Julius
and Ethel Rosenberg,
and adaptations of other
speculative fiction texts
by Theodore Sturgeon, Arthur
C. Clarke, and Mervyn Peake.
So Delany's novella
fits comfortably
into their repertoire.
To my mind, the most salient
image in The Star Pit
is an unspoken word.
To get to the moment
when it's enunciated,
we can start at the beginning.
The program opens
with an announcement
of the title and
provenance of the material
about to be broadcast.
Baird Searles, acting
in his official capacity
as head of WBAI's
drama and literature
department and curator of
the 99.5 Radio Theater,
speaks to delineate
fact from fiction.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- By Daniel Landau,
with Randa Haynes,
Walter Harris, Jerry Matts,
Joan Tanner, and Phoebe Wray.
The narration is by the author.
The music for The Star Pit
is composed and performed
by Susan Schweers.
The technical direction is by
Ed Woodward and David Rabkin.
Production assistant,
Neal Conan.
The Star Pit first appeared
in Worlds of Tomorrow,
published by the Galaxy
Publishing Corporation.
[END PLAYBACK]
- This isn't the last
time we'll hear his voice.
The next sound we
hear is non-diegetic.
According to Delany's
recollections,
it's a flute overture created
by Susan Schweers that
was played on what he describes
as "an instrument made
of industrial
hosing with an inch
and a half bore, and arbitrarily
cut-in finger holes."
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[FLUTE SOUND]
[END PLAYBACK]
This sound signals
a shift from reality
into the fictitious
world of the narrative,
and it's not the last
time we'll hear it either.
The first voice we hear
within the narrative
is that of the author who plays
the role of the first person
narrator named Vyme,
and the first thing
he populates the narrative
with is an object
containing non-human life.
What will it be?
Aliens, sea monsters,
killer robots?
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Two glass panes
with dirt in between
and little tunnels from cell
to cell, when I was a kid,
I had an ant colony.
[END PLAYBACK]
- Ant colony.
As the overture trails
off in the background,
the first words
spoken in The Star Pit
literally frame a
world within a world,
the self-contained
biosphere of an ant farm.
This motif recapitulates itself
several times over in the story
as ecospheres-- big ones as
large as a playground jungle
gym full of animals, small
ones that are wearable behind
a magnifying glass with little
microorganisms in them worn
on a dangling pendant--
become figures for the
limits of life itself.
To the ants from
Vyme's childhood,
the size of the earth
is unfathomable.
But he lets us know that much
greater mysteries revealed
in his lifetime helped make
our entire planet seem quaint.
A flashback, which is set apart
from Vyme's adulthood travails
by another flute
interlude, finds
us remembering his
formative years
at the beginning of a space age.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- I was born in
a city called New
York on a planet called Earth.
Luna is its one satellite.
You've heard of the
system, I'm sure.
That's where we all came from.
A few other things
about it are well known.
Unless you're an
anthropologist, though, I
doubt you've ever been there.
It's way the hell off
the main trading routes
and pretty primitive.
I was a drive mechanics
major, on scholarship,
living in and studying hard.
All morning in
Practical Theory--
a ridiculous name for
a ridiculous class,
I thought then--
we'd spent putting together
a model keeler-intergalactic
drive.
Throughout those dozens
of helical inserts
and super inertia
organus sensitives,
I'd been silently cursing
my teacher thinking
about like everybody
else in the class,
"So what if we can
fly these jalopies
from one galaxy to another?
Nobody will ever be
able to ride in them--
not with the psychic
and physiologic shells
hanging around this
cluster of the universe."
Back in the dormitory,
I was lying on my bed,
scraping graphite
lubricant from my nails
with the end of my slide
rule and half reading
a folded back copy of The
Young Mechanic when I saw
the article and the pictures.
Through some freakish
accident, two people
had been discovered
who didn't crack up
at 20,000 light years
off the galactic rim, who
didn't die at 25,000.
[END PLAYBACK]
- At the time The Star
Pit was written in 1967,
we were overcoming obstacles
to human spaceflight
by relying on
chemical propulsion
and the work of human
computers like the black women
depicted in the
film Hidden Figures.
Within a couple of
years, astronauts
would land on the moon and
return safely to Earth.
As humans reckoned with
the possibility of escaping
Earth's orbit for the
first time in real life,
Delany imagined the
fictitious mechanic, Vyme,
working on flying machines
that would confront us
with new hazards.
The model keeler-intergalactic
drive, to which he refers,
would be the engine for a new
spacecraft intended for travel
beyond the Milky Way.
The moment he is remembering
doesn't refer to its invention,
though.
It was technically
possible to build it.
Instead, it marks the discovery
of the new explorers among us
who would be able to fly it.
In the guise of the head of
some commission that Vyme
is remembering from his
youth, Baird Searles' voice
re-enters the
broadcast to explain
why the few individuals capable
of movement between galaxies
are so exceptional.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- --stellar travel has been
with us for three centuries.
Intergalactic trade has
been an impossibility,
not because of
mechanical limitations,
but rather because of barriers
that till now we have not even
been able to define.
Some psychic shock causes
insanity in any human,
or for that matter,
any intelligent species
or perceptual
machine or computer
that goes more than 20,000 light
years from the galactic rim--
then complete physiological
death, as well as
recording breakdown in computers
that might replace human crews.
Yet, just when we had
to face the black limit
of intergalactic space, bright
resources glittered within.
Some few of us whose
sense of reality
has been shattered by infantile,
childhood, or prenatal trauma,
whose physiological and
psychological orientation
makes life in our interstellar
society painful or impossible--
not all, but a few
of these golden--
[STATIC]
- At this point, there was
static or the gentleman
coughed.
- --can make the
crossing and return.
- The name golden,
sans noun, stuck.
[END PLAYBACK]
- This moment represents the
crux of my interest in The Star
Pit for several reasons.
One reason is that Vyme
tells us in the print
version of this story
that he remembers
learning to use
the term "golden"
to refer to people
who can withstand
intergalactic travel
from hearing it
in the voice of an
authority figure.
The radio production
reinforces the significance
of hearing credible information
in an authoritative voice
by recreating that
moment for the listener,
placing us in the
position we're meant
to imagine Vyme was in when
he hears it for the first time
more than 300 years
into the future.
Another reason this
moment is compelling--
and here is in the grammar
of this fictitious term
of identification for
potential space travelers,
these so-called "golden."
According to Vyme's
recollection,
he's not sure whether there was
static or the gentleman coughed
between using golden
as an adjective
and continuing his locution with
the predicate of the sentence--
"not all, but a
few of these golden
can make the
crossing and return."
In the broadcast, Delany
and his interlocutors
conspire to reproduce the
ambiguity around whatever
prevented Vyme from
hearing the word modified
by that adjective, golden.
The spokesman was
already a bit congested
when he began reporting
the discovery of golden,
and he clears his
throat a few times.
Then, as if to double
the uncertainty,
the sounds of a
coughing fit and static
compete with the voice of
Vyme, saying the lines,
"there was static or
the gentleman coughed."
Even though the story takes
place in the far future,
the community depicted
in The Star Pit
finds out about the possibility
of intergalactic travel
for the first time by listening
to some sort of radio.
An interference of an
indeterminate nature
prevents them from knowing
exactly to whom or what
golden initially refers
apart from the example set
by the persons to whom the term
applies and what they can do.
In this radio play, in its
fictitious future world,
the content of being golden--
being able to travel
between galaxies--
is literally unspeakable.
I'm fascinated by this problem
because The Star Pit also
revolves around the prejudice
that Vyme and his peers
feel toward people
who are golden.
Virtually, all the characters
we meet in the story
regard golden with a mix
of envy and derision.
The plot is driven
principally by a scenario
in which one of Vyme's
friends invites certain death
by pretending to be golden when
he actually isn't, so that he
can steal away on a ship
headed out to deep space
where he, like any
person who isn't golden,
will lose his mind.
The epigraph to the magazine
version of The Star Pit,
which never appears beyond the
title page of the printed text
and is never spoken
in the radio play,
reads, "We were trapped in the
tiny, billion-star backyard
of our own galaxy while the
golden roamed the universe."
For the most part, the actions
of golden within the text
consist of anti-social
behavior and willful ignorance
regarding their privilege.
In light of the
extraordinary liberties
they enjoy, it's hard
not to sympathize
with the protagonist's opinion
that golden are alternately
mean and stupid.
The first direct
confrontation that Vyme
has with a golden character in
the text affirms this attitude.
When he narrowly
avoids a collision
with an intergalactic
spaceship whose pilot as a rule
has to be golden, we
begin to understand
why they attract such an
odd, unnameable resentment,
something that can't be
spoken to any other way.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- We were an hour out, and I was
at the controls and something
I'd never heard of
happening happened.
We came this close to
ramming another ship.
Consider how much
empty space there is.
The chances are infinitesimal.
And on top of that,
every ship should
be broadcasting an
identification beam
at all times, but this big
bulbous keeler-intergalactic
slid by so close I could see
her through the front viewport.
Our inertia system went nuts.
We jerked around in the
stasis whirl from the keeler.
I slammed on the video intercom
and shouted, "you great
big stupid--
stupid--" so mad and scared
I couldn't say anything else.
The golden piloting
the ship stared at me
from the view screen with
mildly surprised annoyance.
I remember his face
was just slightly more
Negroid than mine.
[END PLAYBACK]
- The golden, who almost
crashes into our protagonist,
is phenotypically black,
just like the author,
who is playing the part
of Vyme in the radio play.
Whereas it's stated in
pseudo scientific terms,
the commonality here reminds
me that in the flashback
to his youth, Vyme recalled
the discovery of the first two
golden by using the epithet,
"a little Oriental girl,"
to identify one of them.
This superannuated
vocabulary of racial identity
in the story reiterated
during the broadcast
intensifies my
attention to what goes
unsaid in the fictitious
language community The Star
Pit represents.
While any number of more
benign and less loaded
words for racial
identities assigned
to people with African
and Asian origins
are available at the time
the story is written--
the word Negro, for instance,
appears in the radio play--
the presence of
these outmoded terms
engenders a stark
contrast with the absence
of a referent for golden.
Immediately after his run-in
with the intergalactic pilot,
Vyme struggles to
articulate what's
happened because there are no
words to characterize golden
except "golden."
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- I slammed on
the video intercom
and shouted, "you
great big stupid--
stupid--" The other
pilot came bellowing
from behind the sleeper curtain
and started cursing me out.
"Damn it, it was one of those--"
and I lost all the profanity
I knew to my rage-- "golden."
[END PLAYBACK]
- Delany, the author, is as
adept at using profane language
as he is at crafting metaphors.
But when it comes to creating
a voice and a vocabulary
for this character, the
speaker and narrator,
the antagonism that
golden represents
has to be utterly unspeakable.
golden is a new, unnamed form
of difference within the human,
as well as a new heretofore
inconceivable relationship
between the human and space.
It's tempting to
say the term golden
is tantamount to
profanity all by itself,
although being golden confers
an absolute maximum potential
for mobility across
far-flung galaxies.
And because they're so integral
to intergalactic trade,
the basis of the
economy of the future,
they must enjoy social
mobility in society.
It also coincides with
certain disadvantages
in psychological and
emotional well-being that
limit the life chances
of the larger group
to which all golden belong.
As the head of the
commission said,
golden are a fraction of that
segment of the population whose
physiological or
psychological orientation
makes life in their interstellar
society painful or impossible.
The suggestion here, quite
contrary to the epigraph
that occurs as an editorial
supplement to the story
but whose words are never
spoken within the text,
is that what it
means to be golden
is bound up with what
it means to inhabit
a status of disability.
With this hypothesis
in mind, I want
to shift our interpretation
of the imagery in The Star Pit
away from the abstract,
the far-fetched,
and back toward more
familiar concerns.
Golden is not an allegory for
human difference in general
because there is no such thing
as human difference in general.
There are only differences.
Golden doesn't refer
to any of them.
It's a metaphor that doesn't
have a referent of its own--
in literary terms,
a catachresis.
As Lisa [? Frankel ?]
defines the term,
it's the use of a borrowed
word for something that
doesn't have a name of its own.
Catachresis invokes a world
whose contours and contents
are already shaped but
not named by language.
This is a world that comes
to us already articulated
in process by trope, a
world chewed up by language
before we meaning makers
even arrive on the scene.
A great deal of interest
in speculative fiction
emanates from its
potential to illuminate
power dynamics in the
actually existing world
through metaphorical figures.
Elves bring us face to
face with enslaved Africans
or oppressed workers.
Men experience the
subordination that women
suffer due to patriarchy.
Exoplanets provide the staging
ground for colonial encounters.
Yet frequently I observe
the most valuable insights
a story has to offer about
systems of social advantage
and exploitation occur
in familiar forms.
Trying to explain
why people like Vyme
resent golden, according to the
internal logic of the story,
only takes us so far.
Racial difference persists into
The Star Pit's imagined future.
It hasn't been replaced
or superseded by golden.
Likewise, the presence
of golden in their ranks
hasn't supplanted
prejudice against people
whose physiological and
psychological orientation
makes life painful
or impossible.
It just constructs
a single quality
that they're
predisposed to possess,
namely the capacity to
endure intergalactic travel
without cracking
up, as something
desirable within
certain situations.
The rarity of this
quality is part of what
makes it a source of intrigue.
It inspires the search
for golden prospects
throughout the population,
which underscores their presence
across all putative racial
groups, all sexes, all genders,
on all planets, and implicitly
at many, if not all, ages.
The demand for what golden can
do in the future envisioned
by The Star Pit changes the
valuation of the symptoms
they share with
their peers, symptoms
that present themselves as
disabilities to the point
that characters appear in
the story having matured
under circumstances that
inculcates psychosis where
it wasn't present before--
that is, they acquire the
precipitating conditions
for being golden
on the off chance
that, in a population
with a greater
proportion of
psychotics, there will
be more intergalactic explores.
Within the
protagonist's lifetime,
in the duration of the
story, being golden shifts
from a possibility that's been
discovered to a probability
influenced by intentional
manipulation of variables
that include the viability
of human life itself.
It's a form of madness induced
within a minority in order
to spare the majority of people
from experiencing anything
like it.
How are we supposed
to make sense of this?
In The War of the Worlds, it's
the microbial life on Earth
that spells death for
the invading martians.
No adaptation, no
resistance, no intention
spares humanity from
the conquering violence.
Human survival is
an ancillary benefit
of a massively disrupted
ecosystem brought back
into what passes for equilibrium
by unforeseen, largely
invisible interactions.
There's nothing unique about
the world inside of HG Wells'
imagination that resolves
the problems he's
created in the story.
Ultimately, the
reader or listener
has to borrow knowledge
from the world
that's taught us everything
we know, which also taught
Wells everything
he knew, in order
to understand what happens.
In order to learn from the
way that The Star Pit uses
catachresis to name something
that's simultaneously like
and also unlike
actually existing
socially meaningful
differences, we
need to think critically about
what aspects of the world
as we know it make the idea
of being golden meaningful.
What do we know about
the traumatic situations
that make life
painful or impossible
for some members of society?
How do we know that?
What kind of
stories let us know?
Stories about life being
painful or impossible
for some members of society
are often tragedies,
but they don't have to be.
Tragedy is a genre, just like
science fiction, romance,
and horror are genres.
They are subject
to interpretation.
The Star Pit relies on the
audience's understanding
that congenital
and early childhood
conditions can precipitate
traumatic experiences
in mental health.
However, I think people
keep tuning in to stories
that could be
tragedies or that just
seem easy to place
within a tradition,
based on the tropes
they employ, in order
to find out whether every
instance of storytelling
in the genre will
be a known quantity
or whether it will turn
out to be something else.
So just because the
kind of person you are
has been the
protagonist of a tragedy
doesn't mean that's
what your story will be.
What do we know about the
narrow range of situations
in which symptoms of trauma
that are typically constructed
as disabilities appear to
confer competitive advantages
or adaptive strategies?
What are those stories like?
Whose stories are they?
Who tells them?
The Star Pit is in part
one of these stories,
but it's not the only one.
It's not even the best one.
Some of these narratives
are animated by the figure
of the savant, sometimes
constructed medically
as a person with
savant syndrome,
or in much less benign language
in the time Delany was writing.
Depending on how we regard such
figures and how we interpret
their stories, we bear witness
to a range of solidarities--
to empathy, to
prejudice, to envy,
to ignorance and to
other relations--
that provide the
frame of reference
for what it's like to be
golden and what it's not like.
Given what we know
about the way society
marginalizes people
with disabilities,
what do we know about
the way other forms
of social marginalization,
such as racism and poverty,
influence the meaning
of disability?
If golden belonged
to a population
among whom every
member experiences
painful or impossible
circumstances
due to their physiological
and psychological orientation,
how can we use our
knowledge about what
influences the
experience of disability
to make sense of that?
Disabled people of color tell
the most interesting stories
in this regard and the
most informative stories
because they live at that
intersection of forces
in a way that requires
them to access,
to produce, and to disseminate
knowledge about it.
These are some of
the sources I'm
using to demystify
the role of race
in science fiction radio drama.
And this is where
I have to ask you
in joining me to take a leap
away from sorting knowledge
into disciplines and back
toward the establishing ground
of the way we think
about race and genre.
The Star Pit is a
science fiction story
among other things,
and my research
is as much about stories in the
fantastic genres and the way
they're told as it
is about the story
that science fiction tells
itself about its history.
As I work to understand the
integral part that radio
has played in propagating
speculative fiction,
I'm also working to comprehend
how that mode of storytelling
takes place in a world where
distinctions of medium, genre,
and methodology are not the most
important kind of difference.
Stories like The
Star Pit use language
to depict a changed world with
new differences that matter,
yet they're told in this
world where people see, hear,
and imagine things that are
imprecise and unspeakable.
The way we learn about
these unspeakable things
makes a difference
in whether and how
we understand what
they mean, even
though they can't be named.
Audiofuturism is about
the difference made
by stories that come to
us through the radio,
but it's also about
listening to black people
and finding out what
kind of stories resonate.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]